the following content is provided under  a Creative Commons license your support  will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to  offer high quality educational resources  for free  to make a donation or view additional  materials from hundreds of MIT courses  visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu  so which of the following is a good and  valid definition for class representing  a car okay most of the people I think  have got it gotten it which is the red  which says class car object that's  perfect okay so this defines a function  this defines a class correctly but a is  just not descriptive name at all and  this is kind of weird and this is the  right one here